[Musique]
nous ne sommes plus habitués à côtoyer des gens
qui meurent
[Musique]
nous avons oublié comment nous rapprocher les
uns des autres,
nous pouvons juste faire des tableaux de visualisation
d'éventuelles funérailles fantastiques
[Musique]
à court de soignants
j'aimerais  pour aider la communauté,
quelle que soit la communauté dans laquelle vous vous trouvez, à
être plus à l'aise avec la réalité selon
laquelle la mort est quelque chose qui arrive
à nous tous
[Musique]
Je suis une Doula de fin de vie et on l'
appelle parfois une Doula sourde, certaines
personnes en ont toutes sortes  de noms différents
pour cela, mais ce que je fais, c'est que j'accompagne
les personnes mourantes
et celles qui les aiment et qui prennent soin
d'elles, qu'il s'agisse de la famille ou
des amis
ici à Sparrow, qui sont sur le point d'organiser un
événement qui parle de la mort autour d'
un dessert et de sortir ensemble.  et juste un
cadre vraiment détendu, souvent les gens
décorent des boîtes similaires à celle-ci avant d'
être incinérés, simplement pour
commémorer la personne aussi.
Je facilite en quelque sorte la conversation
avec quiconque vient avec des questions sur
le processus de mort après la mort.
Choix des soins funéraires des gens  ont et comment
ils peuvent vouloir que leur corps prenne soin de
choses comme ça alors alors c'est
magnifique allons à
Seattle c'est tellement joli
[Musique]
beaucoup pour venir c'est merveilleux de
te voir je m'appelle Emma je suis une Doula en fin de vie voici
Erica  beaucoup d'entre vous connaissent
le fondateur de Sparrow
et j'ai vu beaucoup de gens mourir dans ma vie
et je
quittais toujours les funérailles avec le sentiment qu'ils
ne représentaient pas la personne
que j'aimais, cela me restait toujours et
j'avais des idées très claires.  à propos de ce que je
voudrais qu'une maison funéraire ressemble à ce
qu'elle n'a pas vraiment l'air d'
avoir traditionnellement une maison funéraire qui ressemble à ce qu'elle
ne sent pas comme telle,
qu'elle soit plutôt un récipient que les gens peuvent
remplir de ce qui est important  pour eux,
vous n'êtes pas ici seulement pour les morts,
vous êtes ici pour les vivants, vous êtes
ici pour que les gens passent et c'est
comme un espace ouvert pour entrer,
s'asseoir et être dans un endroit qui traite
de la fin de  la vie, mais d'une manière qui nourrit votre
vie en ce moment,
nous sommes des êtres humains, nous avons des corps, mais
nous ne sommes pas seulement nos corps, nous sommes
aussi autre chose et je pense que nous le
sommes, vous pouvez appeler cela un mélange de
désir d'expérience de mémoire  le désir, donc c'est comme
travailler avec la personne dans son ensemble jusqu'à
la mort, mais ici, cela
se produit après et la narration
qui se déroule ici est incroyable, nous avons donc
quelques activités ici, nous pouvons simplement
créer des tableaux de vision de vos
funérailles fantastiques, de ce que vous pourriez être.
j'adorerais me voir là où tu aimerais être
étranger
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
des animaux que j'ai ou que j'associe à la
mort d'une manière dont les gens dans la vingtaine sont
forcément à l'aise pour parler de la
mort Je pense que c'est quelque chose  où il est
tabou d'aimer en parler et où la
mort est quelque chose que tout le monde
expérimente et vivra et je
pense qu'à cause de cela, il devrait y avoir
une sorte de camaraderie entre nous car
les gens aimeraient-ils choisir une question que
j'adorerais oh d'accord quoi  sont
des choses courantes que vous avez vues dans les derniers instants d'une personne
avant sa mort oh c'est une bonne
question au cours des 12 dernières heures,
quelqu'un sort de son sommeil et voit
quelque chose qu'il reconnaît
en tendant la main ou même en s'asseyant partiellement
puis en revenant oui c'est
C'est certainement quelque chose que j'ai vu
[Musique],
soit nous serons la personne mourante, soit nous
serons avec quelqu'un que nous aimons et qui
est en train de mourir et pour nous familiariser davantage avec
cela, je pense que c'est une forme de sagesse de
devenir réaliste à ce sujet et  aussi en
gardant un peu plus la mortalité à l'esprit,
vous vivez mieux